la chronique culture du mercredi je vous
l'avais promis en début d'émission et on
tient les horaires on tient notre parole
johanna bonsoir et on va parler de la
saison de la ferme de belles et basta
lui exactement puisque en octobre et
bien forcément la vie culturelle reprend
son cours peu à peu c'est le cas donc à
la ferme de bel ébat à guyancourt avec
une ouverture de saison prometteuse
puisqu'il s'agit de pentimento un
spectacle de cirque c'est le deuxième
rendez vous après la nuit blanche de la
poésie un spectacle donc familiale mise
en scène par madona bouglione voilà
bouglione la fameuse celui dont on
parlait déjà au début juste madonna qui
met en scène non madonna puglia mais
c'est quand même pas mal aussi
et ce alors que selon elle revisite
justement madona bouglione le lac des
cygnes de tchaïkovski avec 14 artistes
en sait beaucoup 14 artistes portent sur
les disciplines et bien il ya un peu
tout notamment de l'acrobatie du clown
du mime et ça sera donc ce samedi ce
week-end le 13 octobre à 18 heures une
seule et unique représentation
oui en revanche j'ai une autre date qui
peut vous intéresser
wilfrid est chez vous aussi c'est mardi
donc le 16 octobre à 20h30
alors là c'est un spectacle qui
s'adresse à un public adulte à partir de
16 ans il s'agit de la comédie
tchétchène pas toujours très drôle ça
c'est le titre entier car la
particularité de cette pièce de théâtre
assez dure c'est qu'elle a été écrite
par johan lavabre qui est le directeur
de la ferme de bel ébat il a huit ans
qu'il a écrit cette pièce on les écoute
nous ne l'avons rencontré il ya quelques
jours c'est une pièce qui retrace qui
retrace les événements de la prise
d'otage qui a eu lieu à moscou en
octobre 2002 ou
un commando de séparatistes tchétchènes
quarantaine de personnes ont pris en
otage les 800 spectateurs d'une comédie
musicale
quand j'ai commencé à écrire c'était de
l'actualité bon c'est devenu presque un
fait historique maintenant dix ans après
un événement évidemment tragique et
douloureux puisque ça s'est traduit par
par la mort de plus de 160 personnes
dont les 40 preneurs d'otages évidemment
lors d'un assaut qui au bout du
troisième jour a conclu a conclu cette
prise d'otages la question c'était de
comprendre pourquoi un théâtre qu'est ce
qui fait qu'un qu'un commando tchétchène
décide de se situer dans un théâtre
alors ça a été l'argument de la pièce
c'était j'ai voulu répondre à cette
question pourquoi un théâtre sans doute
parce que le théâtre de l'antiquité à
nos jours en passant par shakespeare
mais également par molière a toujours eu
cette volonté d'être un miroir du monde
et peut-être que en ce moment on est
dans une phase où je dirais que le
théâtre voudrait plus nous faire oublier
le monde dans lequel nous vivons que de
nous représenter ce monde et c'est le
parti pris de ce commando tchétchène de
dire mais au fond vous venez au théâtre
assistait une comédie musicale
complètement anodine qui racontent rien
sur rien et nous on vient on interrompt
ce spectacle et on va rendre au théâtre
sa vocation première qui est de vous
raconter le monde dans lequel on vit
et donc ils viennent à moscou raconter
ce que c'est que la vie de deux
tchétchènes comédie tchétchène pas
toujours très drôle c'est le nom de ce
spectacle qui s'amassent acquise alors
c'est donc comme son nom l'indiqué ne
communiquait pas forcément toujours
rigolote on peut rire à des choses qui
sont quand même assez cruel et parfois
les scènes sont durs alors c'est un
spectacle qui s'adresse forcément aux
adultes et aux amateurs de théâtre et
aussi et d'histoire contemporaine faut
savoir qu'à l'issue de la représentation
est bien une discussion avec l'auteur
johan lavabre le metteur en scène bruno
lajara et amnesty international qui fera
venir
un avocat russe spécialiste sur la
question des droits de l'homme dans ce
pays sera organisée vous nous présenter
la saison de la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt quelles sont les nouveautés
de cette saison
alors la ferme de bel ébat continuera de
proposer des ateliers de théâtre
destinés à des publics spécifiques comme
les personnes en rupture avec le monde
du travail ce sera pour avril met
l'accent cette année va être mis sur les
résidences d'artistes
ce qui permettra à la ferme de bel et
bien de présenter des premières de
spectacle lors c'est le cas avec nicolas
liautard et sa petite marchande
d'allumettes en décembre et aussi
godefroy ségal en janvier avec plus que
le tumulte des eaux profondes